voici l'un des chars qui composent
l'arsenal ukrainien
un vieux modèle t64 datant de l'époque
soviétique en cours de réparation
quand il fait très froid 10 commandant
le moteur commence à geler ça peut
prendre de 15 à 20 minutes avant de le
redémarrer
dans un char soviétique explique à son
tour ce capitaine l'équipage est assise
sur les munitions donc si le char est
touché ça signifie presque que 100% de
l'équipage est mort
les chats occidentaux sont conçus
différemment dit-il les munitions se
trouvent derrière un panneau de
protection à l'arrière ce qui fait que
si le char est touché l'équipage
survivra en grande partie
bref des véhicules plus modernes
pourraient changer la donne
entretien après des semaines
d'hésitation le chancelier allemand
annonce finalement sa décision Berlin
enverra 14 chars léopard 2 en Ukraine et
autorise ses alliés à en faire de même
internationals au niveau international
affirme la scholls nous veillons à ce
que ce soutien soit possible tout en
évitant que la situation de s'envenime
pour notre pays
justement quelques heures plus tard le
président Joe Biden annonce lui aussi
l'envoi de 31 chars d'assaut américain
Abrams en Ukraine
Kiev on veut jusqu'à 300 le premier défi
sera de les acheminer jusque sur le
champ de bataille la coalition a jamais
envoyé des armes aussi lourdes et aussi
manque que c'est Charles donc ça ça va
être un très très gros défi il faut
aussi former des équipages rappels cette
expert et des mécaniciens chargés de
l'entretien de ses appareils ça prend
toute une une équipe derrière un char
pour l'entretien
là on parle de centaines de personnes
affectées pratiquement chaque char donc
c'est tout un défi faut pas s'attendre à
ce que ça commence à faire une
différence avant au moins deux mois
mais le jeu en vaut la chandelle les
Léopards 2 tout comme les Abrahams sont
supérieurs aux chats russes généralement
mieux équipés et plus puissant donc ce
que ça va changer c'est que ça va
permettre aux Ukrainiens de monter une
offensive et pour reprendre le terrain
qui a été conquis par les Russes l'un
des objectifs Ukrainiens sera
vraisemblablement de couper le corridor
terrestre qui relie la Crimée à la
Russie des territoires conquis au début
de la guerre l'armée russe ne s'est pas
encore complètement réorganisée elle
mobilise elle s'équipe mais à mon avis
rien n'est possible avant l'été donc
pour les Ukrainiens il s'agit avant
l'été d'être capable de lancer une
offensive pour enfoncer les Russes avant
qu'il ne soit prêt il pourrait donc
falloir un certain temps mais quand ces
chenilles fouleront le seul ukrainien
elle pourrait donner un nouveau souffle
à ses soldats ici Sébastien Desrosiers
Radio-Canada Montréal